ces projets de loi reste décriée par
ceux qui rejette la possibilité d'une
vaccination d'une obligation vaccinale
une nouvelle mobilisation a débuté à 18
heures devant l'assemblée nationale le
cortège a pour destination le conseil
constitutionnel qui doit valider
l'extension de ce pass and iter le 5
août le point avec notre reporter quatre
techniques 50 gilet jaune et autres anti
passe sanitaires sont partis de
l'assemblée nationale aujourd'hui pour
rejoindre les abords du conseil
constitutionnel pourquoi et bien parce
que c'est là qui est examiné le texte de
loi sanitaire en ce moment il compte
ainsi protester contre ces mesures
jugées liberticides et ne veulent pas
assez c'est la mobilisation je propose
de les écouter on est là pour leur
montrer qu on lâchera pas que la liberté
c'est pas du tout quelque chose qui est
qu'on doit arracher avec les dons c'est
quelque chose qui nous est dû notre pays
est un pays libre nous sommes des
gaulois réfractaires n'en déplaise à
monsieur macron et les gaulois
réfractaires ils lui disent non non à sa
politique non à la tout ça là on n'est
pas beaucoup on n'était plus la semaine
dernière on était beaucoup plus le
week-end dernier on sera beaucoup plus
long week-end prochain
y'a pas de soucis on ne lâchera pas la
faire pendant l'été ce clivage va il me
désole de cette façon mais en fait une
fois une fille née c'est les français
contre les français et sans qu'il y ait
effectivement une recherche ou une
discussion qui permettent aux uns et aux
autres de sang temps de s'écouter on est
dans un discours binaire et sur chaque
question on est pour ou les comptes ont
fait des choses sont beaucoup plus
complexes il faut effectivement pouvoir
avoir des horizons discussion et au lieu
d'avoir une information unique et
matraqué à la télé etc
c'est d'avoir des débats entre
scientifiques qui permettre d'avoir des
gens qui font une thèse antithèse
synthèse c'est ce qu'on a appris en
philosophie c'est aussi la démarche
scientifique basée sur le doute et qui
permettent au sida semble d'intégrer des
citoyens dans la discussion
effectivement on retrouve à perdre les
valeurs républicaines qui sont de
liberté a ses lois diversité liberticide
d'égalité serre que tout le monde est
égal devant leur égal devant la loi et
de fraternité qu'on a effectivement
complètement perdu
derniers jours de fortes mobilisations
ont eu lieu pour contester le passé ni
terre alors que le texte du projet de
loi sanitaire poursuivre et son parcours
législatif
le texte a été approuvé après son
passage au sénat sans qu'il ne soit
beaucoup modifié mais l'opposition
parlementaire subsistent le texte est
désormais entre les mains du conseil
constitutionnel saisi par jean castex
mais aussi par 74 députés de gauche
ils ont émis un communiqué commun on
retrouve des parlementaires de la gauche
démocrate et républicaine
la france insoumise des socialistes de
liberté territoire il note que certaines
dispositions en raison de leur caractère
disproportionné sont manifestement
contraire à plusieurs droits et libertés
que la constitution garantit
il pense bien sûr à la liberté d'aller
et venir pour les voyages et loisirs les
bars les restaurants mais aussi au
principe d'égalité car tous ceux qui
souhaiteraient se faire vacciner ne
peuvent pas le faire faute de doses les
sages du conseil constitutionnel rendre
leur avis le 5 ans